plongeons un peu dans la
classe des recrues 2019 parce qu'ils vont
ils ont déjà tout ce qu'ils vont
jouer leurs premiers matchs de la NBA qui, selon
vous, sont tombés au bon endroit, vous les gars,
un très bon repêchage pour tomber dans  le
bon endroit mais je choisirai trois joueurs
qui, à mon avis, en ont vraiment bénéficié et je
dirais que le premier est DeAndre hunter
juste un ajustement idéal pour tout
ce qu'il fait au stade où l'équipe est
à la hauteur des attentes qu'elle a pour lui
comme il y a beaucoup de choses qui
s'alignent pour le chasseur d'entrées, donc je pense
que c'est aussi bon d'une personne que je
vais laisser de côté parce que zion
généralement plus le choix est élevé, meilleure est
l'opportunité et les choix de premier tour
ont beaucoup  des choses qui se construisent et à l'intérieur
sont incroyables, mais vous savez que regarder la
situation pour un premier choix comme si
c'était un peu inutile à mon avis,
car généralement, ils ont une opportunité illimitée de
faire leurs preuves, donc je
dirais oui chasseur DeAndre,
je pense beaucoup à Antoi  ne est pas consterné, je dirais que
Jaret Culver est dans un
endroit absolument fantastique quand on regarde la
façon dont l'équipe lit en quelque sorte la construction
autour de sons drôles, mais les
composés de Karl Towns étant autorisés à être en quelque sorte
lui-même et ayant besoin d'une aile complémentaire
qui ne '  t doit nécessairement être un
buteur principal mais fait une tonne d'autres
choses et et pour culver a vraiment un
faible niveau de compétition et il a une
bonne quantité d'expérience donc il est assez
bon pour entrer devrait pouvoir saisir
ce rôle et et
courir avec ça, ce qui est génial, faire leurs
draps psychologiquement calibre Townsend,
je pense qu'ils sont un bon match, je pense
que je pense que les livres sont un peu l'un de
ces types universels comme je
pense que c'est vraiment difficile évidemment Jimmy
mais regarde étant l'étendue de la scène  comme
je ne sais pas, je pense que
souvent, il agit en dehors d'une phase de sa carrière
, disons et vient de pousser dans une équipe
, puis il essayait de le forcer à être
quelque chose que ce n'était pas si cela avait du
sens  étais-je  comme hé tout
le monde soit l'équipe des prétendants aux séries éliminatoires maintenant et ils
n'étaient tout simplement pas ouais donc c'était là une
exception ouais donc donc un chasseur de cadavres
et une île avec celui-ci mais je suis vraiment
intrigué par Carson Edwards et
sa forme j'ai une sorte de chose à propos de
les classes supérieures parce que je pense que parler
d'analyse, je comprends que les
jeunes joueurs qui entrent dans la ligue, vous le
savez, ont tendance à être un meilleur pari sur le plan du
développement, mais je me demande aussi dans quelle
mesure cela ressemble à une perception qui devient
réalité si vous pensez que les jeunes
gars sont meilleurs que vous.  vous
-même pour leur donner plus d'opportunités en
fonction de l'avantage de
dévaluer la même production d'un
joueur légèrement plus âgé, ce qui est logique, donc j'ai tendance
à regarder d'abord les compétences et pour moi,
Carson Edwards est donc il correspond beaucoup
au moule de ceux-ci comme  des joueurs plus petits
qui ont eu un énorme succès et
quand vous regardez où en sont les Celtics en
ce moment, vous connaissez une excellente
culture d'équipe, même si cela a pris un coup l'
année dernière  vous savez qu'historiquement, ils ont été
très solides et ils ont un
rôle que vous savez disponible pour un garde hors
du banc et un entraîneur qui aime jouer
le genre de jeu de rythme et d'espace qui
lui convient et c'est juste un
tireur incroyable qui  il se trouve également qu'il a un
jeu physique prêt pour le
niveau de force des vétérans du MBA et
je pense qu'il va, je pense qu'il
va avoir non seulement toute une saison, mais je
pense qu'il a une chance de vraiment
s'imposer comme l'un des meilleurs
joueurs de  ce piège d'accord c'était
ouais intéressant
il ne devrait pas aimer il a mangé un Tom situation adorable
j'ai merdé c'était bien ne dites pas à Gendron
si un pilier ne coule pas l'
idée de développement à marée basse rediriger cet
almanach de travail pourrait être une clé certains  complimenter
un hérétique il un paranoïaque CTD arabe
Carolyn à New Towns memc contenance
essence un bronzage Erik Tilghman Suffolk
Jimmy Butler régler ici les
circonstances Macario le génie bonne
chance stella maris Derek a Prius c'est un
cadeau Ari  zona 1 $ brouillon Carson Edwards
un brouillon apparemment les Celtics de Boston
s'incrustent sur les coups de soleil sur l'étrange
charge de singe qui était presque un fait c'est
probablement seulement la pollution seulement une Erica
D la question opposée ont des joueurs
tombés dans des situations pas complètement fausses
mais pas des situations idéales  en
2019 dites qu'il y a tu sais que tu es
un est toujours tu sais que tu ne sais jamais
ce qui peut changer mais oui il y en a
certainement un couple je dirais en ce
moment je pense que c'est plus sur la
situation que le joueur en soi mais
je pense que je  pense que Cleveland est vraiment
intéressant Kevin Porter, surtout
parce que je ne sais tout simplement pas quelle est leur
direction en termes de
retour à ce dont j'ai parlé, comme les gens
aiment avoir un certain niveau de compréhension
de l'endroit où ils se situent et et comment
reflète ce que leur  les expériences passées sont
bonnes et pour un joueur comme Porter, je me
demande quel
sera le système de soutien au développement, je suis sûr qu'ils ont un plan,
je ne dis pas qu'ils n'en ont pas mais  quand
je regarde, c'est toujours plus facile quand un
joueur a un rôle très projetable
même si c'est vous savez passer une
tonne de temps dans la G League ou autre
mais le plan ce serait bien avec l'
équipe comme ça s'ils s'il avait  un
rôle de rotation régulier, je ne sais pas si
c'est le cas, je ne sais pas ce
qu'ils vont faire, mais c'est un joueur qui, je
pense, est très intéressant parce que si
vous allez dans une mauvaise équipe, ma
philosophie est que vous devriez probablement  jouez
vos meilleurs joueurs tout simplement pas de manière illimitée oui
vous devez leur apprendre à mieux faire les choses
mais je ne sais pas si c'est utile
pour certains joueurs de les maintenir en quelque sorte
à un niveau que l'équipe ne
respecte pas si cela fait  bon sens, vous
ne pouvez pas, vous ne pouvez pas dire à un gars qu'il
doit faire chaque rotation en défense si
personne d'autre ne fait bien et qu'ils ont
beaucoup d'incertitude de position, donc c'est
celui qui est intéressant, c'est qu'ils ont
utilisé le choix de premier tour sur lui  donc je
dois je voudrais voir comment cette
situation est Ke  vin Porter Rasheed
Wallace type Je pense que chaque
situation est différente cette année,
votre personnalité est également un
sous-produit de vos expériences,
vous pouvez donc avoir des
caractéristiques de personnalité similaires, mais la vie que vous avez
vécue est à
nouveau comme les choses  que vous avez
traversé saurez-vous changer votre
comportement Je pense que Porter est un
très bon enfant à tous points de vue J'aimerais juste
le voir s'assurer
qu'il est constamment engagé dans quelque chose en
quoi il croit bien
qu'il  peut acheter et ne pas lui donner beaucoup
de temps à s'inquiéter
de la direction que prennent les choses, de la direction que prend cette
carrière, s'il aura ou non
une opportunité à cetera
comme dans ces situations, je veux vraiment
beaucoup de structure, etc.  au jour le
jour, les choses sont prédites
et il y a des mesures de référence que les bonnes
personnes font mieux si vous si vous prenez cela
pour une sorte de gestion de carrière, c'est
ce que nous avons
si vous regardez les employés de Career Management
réagissent beaucoup mieux lorsqu'ils
comprennent comment leur travail s'intègre dans le
tableau d'ensemble et ils réussissent beaucoup mieux
lorsqu'ils sentent que leur travail est
valorisé et quand  ils peuvent voir les progrès
correctement et donc lorsque les joueurs ont
traditionnellement mesuré les progrès au fil des
minutes et des touches, vous savez dans
la production statistique si cela ne
va pas être là de manière cohérente, je pense
qu'il est vraiment important d'avoir un processus
en place qui crée quelque chose d'autre
comme ça n'est pas  juste hé attendez
votre tour
faites tout ce travail mais vous mesurez constamment
votre réussite même si ce n'est
pas dans la manière dont vous êtes habitué aux
modalités pour imposer ad hoc des
affaires de brevet de bébé, mais c'est une sortie
avec les sujets effilés pour  vente holla
holla couple d'individu avec
situation hélas je ne mène pas d'examen à Kevin
Parker jr.  Les condos Cavs Pascarella dans une
situation particulièrement aérienne comme une
attitude de danse de coucou ne concernent que
positivement les spectacles à chaque occurrence
un profit passif sur Josie
Pascal sur Kahanamoku dejado montre un
âne référer Aki
il s'est montré capable du service Tiaras sur des
projets dans une partie éloignée d'un USC
le péché un vecteur chez le mâle Anya Danelle
la compétence d'expertise des femmes l
crystianna peut approfondir envoyer un e-mail Je suis
commissionné Projet d'abord je me déplace
vers demandé de polir ou d'effectuer une manœuvre
interrogée de temps en temps lukela Nyonya Oh
[ __ ] bein okay 14:20 garçon
ceejai rencontré  Kootenai Eric avez-vous déjà
des tests psychologiques disponibles pour
la classe 20/20 non rien rien mais
c'est un processus de compilation d'informations au
cours de l'année et nous avons été impliqués dans la
construction de ce nouveau produit alors oui
oui c'est un plaisir pour le
premier  un an serait mon espoir est de
commencer à vraiment obtenir beaucoup plus d'
informations et ensuite de savoir comment
aborder la construction est chacun des  se
est construit manuellement, ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas automatique, quelle que soit la source
d'information, vous devez vraiment
cultiver la source de l'information
si cela a du sens, même avec
même avec les données de personnalité, vous
voulez vous assurer que vous êtes  tirer les
bonnes informations pour obtenir ce
profil, donc c'est définitivement un
processus, pas toutes les interviews
et toutes les publications sur les réseaux sociaux ne sont pas
dignes ouais, cela gagne en importance pour
les équipes de la NBA, les tests psychologiques
disons que je suis une perspective que je fais  't je ne
veux pas faire les tests psychologiques
c'est mon projet de stock ça va baisser
je pense et l'équipe à droite ce n'est pas vous
savez qu'à la fin de la journée le talent
va l'emporter sur n'importe quoi et
évidemment je pense que nous  savent tous qu'une
équipe va prendre un risque énorme même s'il
y a des tonnes d'indicateurs que vous
savez que quelque chose ne va
pas s'ils croient que le talent en
vaut la peine euh cela étant dit je pense
que nous sommes dedans  une grande époque pour
s'occuper de l'esprit maintenant évidemment
avec chaque équipe devant avoir un
psychologue d'équipe avec une santé mentale étant
une priorité, ce truc n'est pas la
santé mentale et c'est mais si nous allons
commencer par le plus sérieux vous  savoir s'il
y a une prise de conscience
et une acceptation du plus haut niveau
de santé mentale qui va faire
prendre conscience à tout le reste de ce qui
peut être fait lorsque vous faites attention à
qui la personne a fait qui a du
sens comme s'il y avait une raison pour laquelle  quelqu'un
devient déprimé s'il se retrouve
dans une situation qui cause du stress et de l'
anxiété jour après jour sans
soulagement, il peut éventuellement vous faire
savoir que vous connaissez un
type de réponse de santé mentale plus grave, alors ce
que j'espère  car est-ce qu'au fur et à mesure que nous avançons et que
nous continuons à faire plus de recherches, ce qui est
un élément clé de cela, ce n'est pas seulement moi qui
collecte des informations, mais quand nous
avons vraiment vous en savez plus
sur ce qui fonctionne comme quoi quoi
est mieux pour gérer correctement comment
gérez-vous quel est le type de
fréquence savez-vous vous engagez-vous
avec le joueur comme êtes-
vous les rencontrez-vous pour faire un
travail individuel sur une base quotidienne êtes-vous  vous savez,
vous leur faites savoir que vous savez en quelque sorte faire
leur propre chose, vous savez, puis vous
vérifiez par intermittence comme tout
cela, plus nous en savons sur la façon dont
un joueur interagit avec son équipe en dehors
du terrain, plus nous en saurons sur la
meilleure façon de  approchez cela et c'est
vraiment ce sur quoi nous nous concentrons et
j'espère que nous pourrons le refaire
plus tard dans l'année, mais le plus
important est que savons-nous de la
vie quotidienne d'un joueur pendant son
développement  non seulement le travail
qu'il fait, mais vous connaissez le calendrier
qu'il respecte et comment il est
soutenu et c'est énorme en
ce moment, la plupart des données d'analyse
concernent ce qu'un joueur fait sur le terrain,
mais une grande partie de ce qui se passe sur  le tribunal
est un byprod  résultat de ce qui se passe
ouais c'est la zone floue pour vous
ouais nous nous concentrons sur l'obtention de plus d'
informations à ce sujet est essentiel d'accord
Alex guérisseur
la spada Mill Valley a éludé un don
de technologues à la prison de Madonna
frito possible comme une pierre des atrocités
pourraient  assignation à comparaître auditeurs monde le mapa a
participé écologique américain dépasser
sur David Amalia village étaient déguisés
en véhicule pour Donna prix DoCoMo's
compact un court métrage est arrivé avec entre autres
spectacles faire ambassadeur le général Terry
ouais musée de connaissances de domaine conflictuel
dans votre entourage numérique de récitation
préconisé en pisco habituel
honnête sur  Lakota psychologique Serato
déclaration Donna press society Ocampo
Tomas Conterra yo réponse Odessa
college America more jewelry on to
recommend education society know
sexuellement shusuke
limited en raison d'une
incision de Coppola Stoney à Hawaï pour une manœuvre bientôt